Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man's over wings, the T is such a wondrous thing, behind us all come see, come take your place, we're leaving soon for-
At least the last one in this little ship, what a shame.
You know, Metro, these days if you find a quiet corner of space you should be glad there are not many of them, but what you say is true, it really is for the last time.
Sad to think that it's ending.
Our Pierrot is going to be commanding a cruiser.
And our Mercedes is going to be his second officer.
She'll accept the offer I made her and we'll all stay together.
Yes, and I'll be made third mechanic, chief cook and bottle washer.
My duties will be checking circuits, as usual.
What a waste of talent. No telling how far I'd go if I had the chance.
Metro, you're talking nonsense.
You know very well you'll go on as a full partner.
Hey, what do you say a little spin through Nebula NGC 6188, huh?
There's open-faced mining going on and a couple of pretty interesting planets.
Well, what do you say, Lieutenant?
Oh, I think you'd better ask our distinguished scholar and bottle washer.
What do you say, Metro? Are we going to find life in a nebula?
Why not? That one there has a cloud of space dust that absorbs stellar radiation.
With no trace of any toxic gases, a conducive environment for life, so as I say, why not?
But I'd be a little bit careful if I were you. The region is infested with asteroids of irregular trajectories.
Well, Lieutenant, what are you waiting for? Program us for the flight.
Aye, aye, Captain.
Assure you, they possess prodigious power.
Oh, yes, prodigious.
Power, or should I say their power to execute orders, for they can really execute those orders, right?
I give the orders and they execute them real good.
You could say I am the head and they are the arms.
You get it? I give the orders.
All those guys on Omega will have to watch it because we're getting ready for a real, genuine, authentic stroke of genius.
Tell them.
Yeah, what he says, a regular stroke of genius.
But General, it's just that, aren't you afraid with all that force, that power which our science puts into their hands,
that one day these allies might decide to turn against us as enemies.
Bunch of nonsense, all that you said.
You forget, I'm a smart fellow.
They produce for us.
Yes, that's true.
But they're only like a lot of tools.
We've taken intelligent precautions, believe me.
The secrets of how it all works,
the engines and spaceships, the computers, the brains,
that's yours truly.
I mean, it is us, we alone.
Your words be heard on high in the cosmos,
because if they ever did turn against us,
there is no telling how much destruction they could unleash.
Enough of this pussyfooting around, okay?
As soon as we're ready, the universe is ours!
Who is this ally?
Where are you now?
Soon all is going to be revealed, you'll know in good time.
Patience, don't worry, you'll know that in good time.
...are ready and in position for carrying out phase two of Exercise D.Va, Great Computer.
Order operation to begin launch and carry out mission as planned.
Yes, Great Computer, at your orders.
The star is at least four times larger than our sun.
Fortunately, we're shielded from its rays by space dust.
These planets appear to be located at distances favorable to the creation of life.
Optimum distance is 200 times the star's diameter.
Think we should fire on them without warning?
It isn't us they're after, but let's try to get out of their way.
It's really incredible.
Incredible.
We'll have to call Omega.
No, Pierrot.
I don't think that they know we're here.
As far as they're concerned, we're just another bit of asteroid out in space that's gravitated here.
If we send a message, they'll find us, and we'll be vaporized.
Let's find out more.
Yes, you're right, Psyche.
History of the exercise.
Ready, Admiral.
Success for the exercise, Admiral.
Return to base.
Astonishing.
Unbelievable.
It is indeed, I must admit, rather surprising.
Careful now.
They're turning around.
It is astounding.
Every arm of that monster must weigh 100,000 tons.
Altogether, astounding.
Yes, that's why they assemble it out in space where it's a weightless condition.
They come from each planet.
All history, we have never known anything so powerful.
We'll follow them, but now we have to notify Omega.
Okay, Captain, I'm calling now.
Urgent message for Colonel Pierre. Let me speak to him.
Transmit that information to Cassiopeia.
Distraction.
Give the General a chance to feel important.
At your orders, great computer, sending signal.
Suggested General.
That lousy hummingbird again, those busybodies from Omega.
I don't believe it. It's always them.
Whatever I do, they're always right there snooping around.
Can see things. We'll get her. We'll get her.
Capture her and then get her to tell us her secrets.
How she doesn't, yeah.
With her mental powers, we'll be invulnerable.
General, in our last encounter with her, we learned nothing.
She learned all.
You let her get away, you clumsy idiots.
Only this time, you gotta hold on to her.
That nuisance with her, I don't care what you do with them.
Just get them out of the way.
But that psyche, don't let her get away.
She's got special powers.
And that's not all she's got, Chief.
See you around, Chief.
I'm certain these are the same ones that we saw back when we were on Saturn.
Humanoids?
Can't shoot our way out. There are too many of them.
Don't do what they say. We'll have to trick them.
If we can make it as far as that spacecraft before they fire on us, we can use it for cover.
Let's try.
I think we're inventing a new sport.
It's like being a clay pigeon in a shooting gallery.
Fire back. What do you think?
In my view, they're not firing to shoot us down.
They're only trying to impress us. Otherwise, we would already be space dust.
Remember Jurgle's lesson?
Well, now we can check on whether you're right, Metro.
If not, so long.
Starting engines.
Stabilizers.
All damage. Emergency landing gear. Now it's our only hope.
Well strapped in, Metro? I'm really sorry, only we haven't enough landing equipment. We only have two, not three.
I know, I know. I assure you I am much more shock resistant than you think, my friends.
Now you go on. Don't waste any time. And I'll be seeing you.
We're there. We'll live. Came down near here.
Lizard men. Regions infested with them.
One we seek has fallen into their clutches very long since ceased to be a problem.
It looks as if they've left. We must remain watchful all the same. They will return.
He is still delirious.
And this one had to fight the Lizardmen for,
and whom we must keep hidden from those up in the castle
who will soon scrutinize our region.
What misfortune is yet to befall him?
We are human, Robert, and we care about him.
All right, Sylvia, we'll take care of him.
You take care of him.
Medical services must make her strong enough
to voyage from Epis to Yama.
Pan in the captain.
No sign of individual, great computer.
We are continuing the search.
Have alerted all units.
This is annoying.
He must be found and liquidated.
Otherwise, the entire D.Va plan may be compromised.
Use every available need to locate him or his remains, Class A priority.
Order understood. It will be done, Great Computer.
Ah, you are awake. You gave us a great deal of worry. Now we are relieved.
All of us now want to welcome you to our planet Apis.
Well, this is as far as we go. Now we go back.
Why should we go back now? It's very nice around here. Let's look around.
No, Piero, we can't. There are creatures here that are terribly dangerous.
And don't forget all of those up in the castle that are looking for you. They're worse.
But then why do you stay here, Sylvia? It sounds like an awful place.
That's just it. Nobody would ever think of looking for us here.
You see, we are outlaws, rebels. There's just a handful of us.
My brother Giglio is a leader. He's the only person I have in this whole world, and I have...
Watch it, Sylvia!
Hero?
Quickly, to the cave.
Little farther.
This is going to be a very short trip, you will see.
Where are you taking me?
To Yama.
The neighboring planet, our big sister.
It is she who directs the whole system.
All living conditions are better there.
And you will be very well cared for.
Everything is there to treat your illness.
We are only a lookout post here, only a few of us.
The real fight is on Yama, the neighboring planet.
That is where the castle is, the enemy headquarters.
Here, life is too harsh, too hard.
For example, even the Cassiopeans who came to settle here couldn't bear it and left.
That will give you an idea.
A new race took their place.
They built another base.
They were insensitive to the climate and wild animals,
to everything that makes human life difficult.
Why?
Because they are robots, no more, no less.
They are making terrible weapons of destruction, experimenting.
But you had a demonstration.
Chief, they have taken the young lady over to Yama.
Your young friend left the planet this morning aboard a spaceship.
A frigate of the official fleet took her to Yama.
Where can I get a ship so that I can go there?
You want to get a spaceship?
You must be dreaming, my land. A spacecraft from Apis? Oh, no.
It's of utmost importance, I assure you, and it seems to me we're fighting on the same side as I see it.
You have to help me.
Better you should wait here.
There are two advantages.
One, they think you're dead, and the castle people won't look for you.
Two, you should get your strength back.
No, there isn't any time to lose.
Listen to me. We have no spacecraft, and I don't know where you'll get one.
Unless Murdoch would do it.
There is no guarantee that he'd agree.
He's a smuggler and a sort of bandit, I guess.
But he's a thousand kilometers from here.
Will you take me to him?
A thousand kilometers across this wretched land,
infested with creatures more ferocious than those in any nightmare,
with every enemy patrol out looking for you.
No thanks, I'd rather not.
Omega will reward you.
Listen to me, Captain.
Rewards are of no interest to us.
No reward you could name is worth facing what is certain death.
All right, show me the direction I'll go alone.
You'd be a fool to go alone.
You know nothing of this planet.
And you, Robert, you don't know me.
I've been in tighter situations than this, and I've found a way out of them.
I will go with them.
If I have to die, I'd rather go down fighting. I'll go.
I'll go with you, too, Piero.
Good care of those weapons.
There are most precious possessions here.
Giglio, you look worried.
Piero, you have been warned there can be ugly surprises around any corner.
With every step, we're walking into danger.
Stay alert if you want to stay alive.
Oh, what a climate.
What place? What sort of creatures are we going to find?
You'll see.
But in any case, they'll mean trouble.
That I guarantee.
The first ones we'll encounter are the Qubies.
With any luck, they'll let us have a mount.
If they don't give us one, it's unlikely that we'll ever make it alive.
Well, if it's really as bad as you say, as dangerous, why did you agree to go with me?
It's not for you. I want that understood.
It's for my sister. She's all that I have.
These Qubies, at least, they're friendly, I hope.
I thought I'd already explained that.
Nobody is friendly anywhere on this planet.
The Qubies are, if you like, a little less ferocious than the others, but that's all.
Stay here till nightfall, because in the light, their gun sights couldn't miss us.
We may as well eat something. We'll need all our strength.
Piero.
Edge of the QBs.
Watch out!
Run, it's not healthy around here.
Friends, don't shoot us. Take us to your leader.
As to give them a weapon.
We do.
I still have my pistol.
Only keep an eye on them once they got it.
I think we should have waited till dawn.
Piero, we left where they realized that three weapons are better than one,
and that it wouldn't be difficult to get all three.
Giglio, let's head for the hummingbird.
It must have come down somewhere around here.
No, lose too much time.
Take unnecessary risks.
But we'll go there anyway. I insist. Let's go.
I'm beginning to wonder if they'd show up around here.
That is anyone civilized, not one of those ghastly robots again.
Metro! Knew I'd find you!
Tell me, how are you, Metro?
That pile of debris isn't gonna make things any easier.
This pile of debris has already performed heroic services, even saved our lives.
You'll see what I mean very soon.